when i was 27 years old i just sold all
of my gyms and put all of my money into
a new venture
and lost all of it and so i had a
thousand and thirty six dollars when i
was 27 years old
two years later i had over 17 million
dollars in my bank account
it was because i accidentally stumbled
into one of the four ways that fortunes
are made
all right it's one of the key things
that we have to understand and we're
trying to break down today
is one the difference between money and
wealth two the four types of leverage
that exist
and then within those types of leverage
permission and permissionless leverage
and how you can harness those things in
your business so that you can make them
into things that can build fortunes
so the first thing is understanding what
is money right money
is simply the way that we transfer
wealth from one person to another
all right that's all it is it just
functions as a medium of transfer it's
actually not in
it of itself valuable it's valuable in
so far as it allows us to acquire
assets which gets us to the second
column which is wealth
this is what you want and that's why
there's a difference between rich people
and wealthy people
wealth is about assets that earn while
you sleep meaning that you don't have to
trade any time
to have these assets make you money and
so one of the things that i think i got
from
taylor walsh was um poor people do the
wrong things
rich people do the right things wealthy
people own the right things
and so as you're transitioning through
life you have to think about am i am i
someone who's doing the right thing
or am i somebody trying to own the right
things and so uh
for example lawyers doctors accountants
they can never really make crazy money
they can't they cannot get
wealthy super wealthy unless they
transition from
being a practitioner or they're training
time for dollars into owning an entire
practice of lots of doctors working for
them which means they then they have
created an asset which then generates
wealth while they sleep right it
generates money while they sleep which
is what makes it into wealth
all right and so if you look over the
last hundreds of years we're talking 500
000 plus years
fortunes have been made in four ways in
the beginning so this is then the first
way
was through labor all right and the
reason labor is the first way of gaining
leverage is because there was no other
way of getting it that's why the kings
and queens had hundreds and hundreds of
servants that's how the pyramids were
built
right that's how rockefeller was able to
build his oil
across the united states right was
through labor right
and so because of that he didn't have to
trade his own time for dollars he was
able to buy
other people's time right now labor is
the hardest type of leverage to employ
it'll impress your parents but it won't
actually it's one of the hardest things
to employ anybody who knows who has
50 100 500 plus employees understands
that it's one of the hardest things to
employ but it is
one of the things one of the four ways
of gaining leverage and one of the key
tenets of these first two
is that these are permission based
leverage you need other people's
permission you need to
you need to appease others in order to
use this type of leverage
the second type of leverage which is
also still permission based
is capital all right that's money
specifically other people's money and so
just an example of what capital is
is let's say i want to buy something um
that
doubles in value uh over five years all
right and let's say i get somebody to
give me a hundred percent of the money
to buy this thing
right and so after five years i have to
repay the person back
but that thing doubled in value right so
let's say it was a hundred dollars when
i bought it from someone else's money
and then it's 200
after five years well i have to pay back
the hundred dollars plus some interest
but then everything else i get to keep
and so that is a type of capital where
if you think about how much
my returns were they were basically
infinite because i didn't put any money
down
right and that is why capital has been
the second main way that fortunes were
built
this is where the the newer billionaires
newer they're still old now
billionaires were created this is the
buffets this is the monger this is the
carl icons of the world
who made their wealth through financing
and using other people's money as
leverage both of these things you have
to ask for permission people have to
give you the money they have to
you have to take that money under terms
under which you're going to give it back
right now the new way of creating wealth
there are two of them
and they are permission permissionless
all right so here
you don't need any permission in order
to use these things and that is what
the new fortunes are being made of the
first
is through code all right so this is all
the big software companies that you see
the tech
giants that exist they use code
for permissionless leverage because
with code it costs zero dollars to have
an additional person consume or get
utility
from what the code does right and so if
you have a piece of software that's a
crm
adding a hundred users or adding a
thousand users
costs you no additional amount for that
one more user
all right and so that is why code is one
of the things that's created fortunes
in the present day now if you're like
well alex i don't know how to
write code well then let me tell you the
fourth way which is the one that i
accidentally stumbled in when i switched
my business from a service-based
business which was just
selling other people's time to a media
business
which was number four which is media
now if you think about the tycoons that
exist out there zuckerberg
he's media he sells eyeballs he sells
impressions google
sells impressions they sell media right
bloomberg he used old school media so he
was the
news he was radio all that kind of stuff
all of that was in his
network and the beautiful thing about
that is that when you have media
you have a captured amount of eyeballs
you can continually sell those eyeballs
and as they grow
you just continue to sell them and it
costs no incremental amount and so the
gross
margin in this are basically 100 percent
there's no added cost
and so you've heard me talk about having
good margins in a business these are the
ways
that you get the exceptional world class
margins which is what builds
fortunes right and so for me when i
transitioned my
company from doing a done-for-you
service where i used to fly out as a
sales team and
fill up locations of brick and mortar
facilities to licensing media
i was able to sell at zero incremental
cost because of that
my margins went through the roof and
that was what enabled me to acquire
money which i was then able to transfer
into wealth
all right now if you're thinking right
now like well there's some places like
you know
is google code or media the answer is
yes it's both
and so if you can employ multiple types
of leverage then you juice the returns
even more
and so that's why all the super wealth
that is being created a lot of times
it's
using two or three of these types of
things they're taking other people's
money
to get other people's labor to write the
code that then they sell as media once
they acquire
all of the eyeballs and that's the
winner takes all games that are existing
right now
but right now if you're like well i
don't know how to write code well that's
okay i don't either
and so that's where we take things like
this youtube channel this is why
joe joe rogan can sell his podcast for
100 million dollars
you can sell ad space because he owns
media and so right now this is where you
can
create blogs for no money you can create
youtube videos for no money you can
anything you can make you can make
podcasts for no money all of these
things you can do
as media to distribute at zero
incremental cost
and that is how fortunes are built and
over time as you can see
it gets i want to say easier to build
fortunes which is why now is the best
time to be alive
out of any time can you imagine a time
where you there weren't just
fun you couldn't just raise capital you
couldn't just have accredited investors
that you could call up
these things didn't exist it was just
the time of labor it was the time of
pyramids
right but as time has progressed the
ways to build fortunes have increased
and the level of permission that's
required has decreased right if you are
the best coder in the world you can
build something that no one else can
build
if you are the absolute best at
providing value at capturing attention
then you can do this and you can create
your fortune with no one's permission
and that's the beauty of being alive
today and so if you're looking about
your own business and you're thinking
about how how can i make my business
more valuable
try and tap into one of these four types
of leverage because if you do that
i can guarantee you will make more money
and you'll have a chance at building one
of these super fortunes
and i was very fortunate to have
stumbled into this fourth one
and now i look for it deliberately so
hope you found that valuable
are as valuable as as it was for me when
i started thinking about this stuff
and i'll see in the next video